Now that we've run the model and we
know what we're going to be looking for,
I'm going to walk you through
the main points of this output.
The first thing I look
at is record number 3,
which is going to show us what
type of forest model was it?
It's a classification, since we're
trying to classify this non-binary data.
The number of trees.
So how many trees did
we build in this model?
So that ensemble is 500 trees worth.
The next thing I look for
is record number 4,
which is the OOB estimation
of the error rate.
Or the out of the bag
estimation error rate.
As you can see,
this is quite low at 3.5% and
this is the bootstrapping
that I mentioned before.
Over on options 5 and 6,
you can see the classification
are confusion matrix which shows
us how many items were predicted
correctly within each bucket and
were there any trends or not?
And overall, you can see that both the
bike and the cars were predicted quite
well, but the public transportation
was a lot worse at 9%.
But overall, all of them are under 10%
which I would consider quite good.
But again,
this is only off the estimation data so
we can definitely go and compare
this to then the validation results.
What I see in plot number
8 is the percent error for
the different number of trees.
This is important because on the x-axis,
we have the different trees.
And so, as you remember,
we put in 500 trees into this model.
And, as we increase in the number of
trees, what does the error occur for
all of the different options, for
the bike option, for the car option, and
the public transportation?
As you can see, with no trees, we have
very high error rates, obviously.
But, with more trees, it definitely
flatlines at a certain point.
And wherever it flatlines,
that's typically the most number
of trees that are actually needed.
But having too many trees in our
model that are not actually necessary
is definitely going to take the model
a little bit longer to run.
So we typically want to go and
remove some of these excess or
unnecessary trees in future run.
So maybe I might reduce this
to 200 trees to be safe.
The last thing I'm looking at
is the variable importance plot
which is the exact same thing we saw
in the decision tree models before.
We're able to see that
the drive distance in miles and
the age categories are very
important in this force model.
But the marital status and
gender provide no real help in trying
to predict what mode of transportation
these employees
are going to take to work.
And as you can see, this is based off
a sign called the Mean Decrease in Gini
but overall, we're not going to
go into that too much.
But if you do want to,
there are some reading notes
that inform you what this Gini
coefficient actually means.
But overall, the way to interpret
this is the higher the values
are on the y-axis and
further over on the x values.
That represents that there
are more important to the model
than the ones over to the bottom left.
So these two are very important.
These provide a little
to no importance at all.
So, overall, with these results,
I'm going to go back up to this
OOB estimation of the error rate,
and this confusion matrix.
And, I see that we only had
an error rate of about 3.5, so
I think this model's pretty good.
But like I mentioned before, we need to
try our model out on a validation data
set to determine how well it
predicts with independent data.